thomas frank is an author youtuber and
creator of the college info geek website
which is an immense collection of
resources that anyone can use to improve
their lives
he went from being obsessed by tech at a
very young age
teaching himself how to build a website
when he was 12 years old to transforming
his passion for learning into one of the
best
love resources for students
need motivation that's a top 10 video
with believe nation
top 10
all my life
hey it's evan carmichael and you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push
by surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
thomas frank and my take on his top 10
rules for success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one start
small what's a tip that you might have
for somebody who's trying to be more
productive where do you even start with
that really
i think the biggest thing is to start
small so one of the
one of my favorite lessons i learned
early on in college came from this book
called the motivation hacker
by this guy he's a quantified self dude
out in
california and he tried to do all these
crazy habits all at once
and kind of documented his journey and
talked about what he learned and he had
this concept in the book talked about
called success spirals
where you have to start very small when
you're wanting to build a habit
and then you kind of spiral up and you
add more difficulty you add more habits
over time
because you're sort of leveling up and
then if you fall off you need to start
small again
you can't start immediately we were so
what i see in most
people who start following me and asking
me you know how do i become more
productive
they want to do all these things all at
once start getting up it's five in the
morning they want to start journaling
you want to start meditating
start reading you know a book a week all
this kind of stuff and you can't do it
immediately
so the biggest thing for me is to find
something that speaks to you
and start with that and make sure you
can get it really solid so start with
one yep and then start small what do you
mean by
start small uh it could be so say you
want to start doing pull ups every day
start by doing one pull-up a day or
start by just making yourself go to the
gym
and just getting there that's you know
that's the accomplishment for you yeah
and then start moving forward because a
lot of people
they see like a recommended program from
a pro online and they'll say okay i'm
going to do that every single
day because that's what i need to do but
when you haven't spiraled up like nick
says you can't stick with that kind of a
program unless you're some sort of
you know ridiculous discipline robot so
you want to start smaller and then
eventually you can stick to that
kind of a big program rule number two
develop your skills
and there's another thing that people
need to realize regardless of
what a person like me or a person like
you is
known for being skilled as maybe um
a podcast or a youtuber or an athlete
there's like a meta skill
that each of us has i don't want to say
mastered but gotten very good at
and that's presenting ourselves very
well in mass media
that's why our president is somebody who
was in the media
and this started i think with ronald
reagan it's people who know how to
how to use mass media tools to make
themselves look very good and to deliver
a message
so people at home who haven't practiced
that skill look at people like
us assume that they don't see that
they just see that oh we're a god of
productivity
or a god of podcasting or like the best
filmmaker ever or something like that
rule number three get rid of i don't
feel like it
what was that first youtube video that
you're like oh this is a thing
uh so the youtube was actually pretty
interesting so that was i guess well it
was four years of just blogging and
podcasting
youtube became a thing because
i have friends at a company called
fizzle who make video courses
for content creators like that's their
business basically
and they also had a blog which i was a
big
religious follower of and a podcast and
one day i saw them post
a snippet from their video course on
productivity
as a blog post and they said hey guys
we're just going to try doing some video
content on the blog as like a sort of
way to
to shake things up and i said i'm going
to do that
yeah that seems like an easy way to get
into video just as like a way to make my
blog content
more diverse so it wasn't really me
trying to become a youtuber
it was just me making a video for my
blog
as a hosting service hmm but i liked the
process and so that got me started
watching a bunch of youtubers
and i kind of i came in at the game
reviewer space
so i was following people like jontron
and peanut butter gamer and categorist
people like them
so a lot of my early videos actually
look like theirs but it's just for like
productivity hacks
yeah and i think it was my my seventh
video
that kind of hit it big got posted to
read it and that was like read it
oh i'm a youtuber now wow what was the
title of this
um i don't feel like it is a mindset for
amateurs
and there's a funny story behind that
video because i had put myself on a
strict once per week video schedule and
i will tell you like how strict it was
in a second because there was money on
the line
oh yeah and i had planned this big
video on the 80 20 principle or the
pareto principle
uh but my script was just crap and it
was friday
and that was supposed to be posting day
and i'm like there's no way i can film
this video
so i was like i just really don't feel
like posting
this week and then i was that was like
the the light bulb
because i was like wait a minute just
because i don't feel like it doesn't
mean i don't have to do it like i can
still do it
so i just made a video on that idea it's
just like when you don't feel like it
that doesn't limit your choices rule
number four use the 20-second rule
well there's this book called the
happiness advantage by a guy named sean
aker
and it contains one of my favorite
principles about habit building
which is what he calls the 20-second
rule so the whole idea is if you want to
build a good habit
make sure it takes less than 20 seconds
to start doing it so
steve's example is great have the violin
right in the living room every time you
pass it it's just right there you can
pick it up and play it
i do the same thing with my guitar so i
went out and i bought a really nice
guitar recently but it's
it's nice and i live in a dry climate so
i have to keep it the case
all the time with a humidifier and that
makes it kind of a pain
to take out and play so i keep my cheap
guitar
so i can have it on the living room all
the time i end up playing that guitar
probably
75 of the time but that guitar ensures i
play every single
day just because it's out yep and that's
why
i've gotten as good as i have also if
you want to have more confidence
motivation and self-love check out my
254 series they're free
the links join on the description below
but i'm interested in your opinion let's
go around the room
it's too late the skill to hold your
opinions to yourself until everyone has
spoken
does two things always pushing yourself
forward always demanding more
and seeing the beauty and what you can
become and knowing that even today
as a caterpillar with nothing two years
before kind of started getting big when
cereal came out and everyone else
started to do them rule number five
find your drive does it also in a way
light a fire under your ass to be like
i am my existence day to day is very
mundane and i'm not
being challenged this is the life i
don't want and
in a way does it motivate you or is
there a potential to get stuck even
further and just be reliant on that
income
i'm not sure i think both can happen
depending on the kind of person you are
and i would have to say honestly my
negative experience in the internship
that didn't light the fire under my ass
to make me work harder
what did was the concurrent success of
the blog
because i went into that internship
during the same summer where that life
hacker thing happened
i think i could be wrong about that i'm
getting my timeline screwed up yeah
oh no i was actually a year no no yeah
you're right it was it was
life hacker thing happened i went into
my internship and
nights and weekends i was blogging and
trying to build this thing up
so i'm at work every single day hating
it but then i'm coming home every single
day
building this thing and the internship
ended and it wasn't like oh i don't want
to go back to that life it was more
i was just so excited about what was
growing over here rule number six
keep a journal i got done with that
internship and it kind of coincided with
my blog
sort of i don't know if blowing up is
the word but becoming a thing that i
thought i could actually so that was
your name
it was my point where it's like i hate
doing this and i'm very glad that i kept
a journal during this time
because now as an entrepreneur sometimes
when it gets hard you start to think
grass is greener it would be so much
easier if i went back and uh
just had a full-time job where i don't
have to think about work
i was thinking about that so i go back
and i read my journal entries
and it just straight up says like i feel
like i'm in prison
and i don't want to like put out there
like anybody working a full-time job as
a you know
corporate slave or something yeah i'm
not one of those people but for me it
felt like that
uh and it's interesting when you look
back on things you don't remember
all like the bad or boring parts you
kind of looked through
rose tinted glasses and you start
thinking well that might actually be
better than what i'm dealing with now
uh so keeping a journal was very helpful
rule number seven
follow a netflix rule is there like an
expectation versus reality with uh
any kind of online persona or
quote-unquote influencer
where people see some they might see a
video from you where you're breaking
down five tips to help you with your
productivity
and then they automatically assume that
you are a productivity guy and that
your life is perfect and you there's
this like kind of weird
expectation versus reality oh i
guarantee you a lot of people think i'm
a productivity god
but my girlfriend sitting in the room
over there she knows that i'm not
so i actually do make an effort to
to show my flaws on social media like i
will show myself
failing at an athletic thing on
instagram sometimes or
i remember one time i posted just me
trying to get this one lick right
50 times and it just sounds horrible but
i want to show people like
you're looking at my highlight reel and
you're looking at a meticulously crafted
script most the time
and every single week i'm giving you
guys a new productivity tip i could not
physically do all of these things and i
definitely don't i'm an imperfect person
and when it comes to that expectation
versus reality thing
i think that can also lead to uh fear
when you're meeting someone like that
so i live by something that i like to
call a netflix rule
and this is basically an assumption in
my head that whether it's arnold
schwarzenegger or gary vaynerchuk or
oprah winfrey
these people as successful as they are
and as self-disciplined as they are most
the time
are probably going to go home tonight at
some point kick off their shoes and
watch netflix because they're tired
and maybe they're going to order a pizza
because it's been a long tour
and they're just very stressed and hey i
do those things too
which means that we're alike in at least
one way
and that means that we're not completely
separate beings so there is
some degree to which we can connect and
that just
kills that intimidation factor rule
number eight figure out what you want to
do
i went to iowa state university and i
majored in mis
so that's management information systems
basically
take a little bit of business take a
little bit of i.t with a lot less math
throw it together you get a major so i
went into
college wanting to be that guy who sits
in the basement of a huge corporation
with all like the matrix computer
screens around me
yeah that's what i thought would be
interesting to do and then i did it
and i hated it you actually need some
light
well so yeah i thought that was
interesting from a conceptual standpoint
but as i got into college and did uh
several part-time jobs i started to
realize
i want a job where i can be active as
well like i don't want to be a cubicle
monkey
so i started kind of narrowing my focus
toward networking because
i figured networking would be building
networks
um and i've since learned that that's
like that's like its own discipline
but what i ended up doing in my
internship was cubicle monkey work
really yup uh i think my job was
basically just to
change firewall settings and i had to
write up a document every single time
it was pretty bad you had to get open
word write exactly what you're gonna do
send it through three different levels
of approval and then do it
so it was pretty bad and that was like
the entire job and that taught me
number one i already knew i didn't want
to be a cubicle monkey but number two it
actually taught me that i'm not built
for maintenance work
i'm built for creative work i would
imagine that you are the same
uh so you figured that out after college
well no that was my internship after my
sophomore year
so luckily i did not have to go into the
real world and
get a full full-time job full-time for
three months
but that was interesting like you don't
know
what you want to do until you go out and
do some things that
you don't like rule number nine give
i think the philosophy is what you've
been talking about for years
give give give you know always be trying
to give and
try to give people as much as possible
on the platform
don't don't be so concerned with getting
people back to the thing you created
because what you really want to do is
become a known quantity in that
community
and rule number ten the last one before
a very special bonus clip
is build discipline in book five of
meditations aurelius writes
at dawn when you have trouble getting
out of bed tell yourself
i have to go to work as a human being
what do i have to complain of if i'm
going to do what i was born for the
things i was brought into the world to
do
or is this what i was created for to
huddle under the blankets and stay warm
but it's nicer here so you were born to
feel nice
instead of doing things and experiencing
them don't you see the plants the birds
the ants and spiders and bees going
about their individual tasks putting the
world in order as best they can
and you're not willing to do your job as
a human being why aren't you running to
do what your nature demands
but we have to sleep sometime agreed but
nature
set a limit on that as it did on eating
and drinking and you're over that limit
you've had more than enough of that but
not of working there you're still below
your quota
you don't love yourself enough or you
love your nature too and what it demands
of you
people who love what they do wear
themselves down doing it they even
forget to wash or eat
do you have less respect for your own
nature than the engraver does for
engraving
the dancer for dance the miser for money
or the social climber for status
when they're really possessed by what
they do they'd rather stop eating and
sleeping than give up practicing their
arts
he's telling you to respect your choice
of path in life enough that you consider
it to be your very nature to be instinct
just as spiders and bees and ants get up
every day and are driven by their
instincts so should you be driven by the
actions that are demanded by your goals
if yesterday you decided you wanted to
get up early so you could work on your
goals but now you're lying in bed and
you feel
comfortable and you don't want to get up
then you need to focus your mind
on your nature on the path you've chosen
and let that override
your current desire other aspects of the
art of gaining self-discipline like
exercises for building grit or systems
that commit you to things ahead of time
are
important but they take a back step to
this one key insight
for marcus aurelius respecting your work
as your very nature
and tailoring your decisions and actions
in accordance with that was the most
important part of building discipline
now i've got a special bonus gift from
thomas on how to make the most out of
books
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i wanna know where do you
need more discipline in your life let me
know put it down in the comments below
and if you're still here watching and
you promise you commit let's go believe
nation
we don't just watch videos here we do
something about it if you're gonna
commit to taking action today
give me a hashtag believe in the
comments below i want to
celebrate you i also think it's it's not
healthy to be overly concerned though
with the best books
because number one you're basically
relying on other people's opinions
but number two a book may not be amazing
for some people but it might
because of your particular circumstances
or your particular goals it might send
you along a path
that ends up being very rewarding for
you um
and that might not have happened for
somebody else uh and like we were
talking about earlier
don't finish bad books you know if you
find out that the book you chose is
really not worth it then
put it down your time is worth more than
the it's hard to put down a book though
because once you start it you kind of
feel like you have to finish it
yeah i think we believe that because
we see all these people on the internet
who say they read a book a week or they
got this goodreads profile with
a thousand finished books or you know
we've been taught to finish what we
start
but the end goal of a book isn't to
turn the last page i mean that really
doesn't do anything for you
the end goal of the book is to get
something out of it or to enjoy the
process of reading it so
if a book is doing neither of those
things for you
you know barring the whole advice to
stick things out you know because they
may be worth it in the long run
if something is just not worth your time
then it's not worth why
right yeah so let's say you grab a book
that is
useful for you how do you make sure you
apply what you
actually read in that book instead of
just what most people do is they close
it
and then they move on to the next book
yeah um
number one it's good to take notes or
summarize so my favorite way of taking
notes is to sort of read the chapter and
then
either jot down notes in a bolt list or
just a summary into evernote so you
don't write notes as you're reading
nope i uh i because i find that it just
slows down my reading process
so with some books i'll use like those
book flags or a highlighter and maybe
highlight certain sections or make a
mark in the
margin but i don't like to pause and
take notes like to kind of immerse
myself it makes sense
the other thing is i also listen to a
lot of audio books
um a huge commitment of mine is to have
a lot of physical activity so
in some days i can't sit down to read
but i always listen to an audiobook
so i'll either summarize or with audible
you can pause and you can
put a note in the app just kind of nice
and then
i think it's again it comes down to
starting small selecting something from
the book that speaks to you more than
everything else and trying to implement
that
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer on this channel i
have a dedicated brand new channel just
for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there